the reason i am calling you today is\h
because as you may know i've got a\h\h
keen interest in the the pioneers that went to\h
japan uh years ago and got the chance to practice\h\h
with all sensei being in japan myself the story\h
is about people like yourself uh have been very\h\h
uh influential in deciding me to go to japan now\h
of course i didn't get the chance to uh to meet\h\h
or sensei myself uh but uh you know that's perhaps\h
my way to compensate for that is actually together\h\h
the stories of the people who wear so uh\h
as you may know i uh i met alan roddock\h\h
henry connor i did meet uh ken cote as well though\h\h
i didn't know him uh personally i\h
just you know attended some seminars\h\h
and you know like uh because i've prompted\h
those people to uh to tell me their stories uh\h\h
of course your your name and that of others came\h
up and then um last january during the kamibiraki
i was at home at that time and you know when\h
they unveiled the names of the promoters\h\h
i saw that your name was there as i ate stan\h
and and i thought oh yeah that's true i still\h\h
have work to do in you know in recording so\h
those uh those stories so there there you go\h\h
that's the the that's what it is of course uh\h
you know i need to thank bob coleman for for\h\h
putting us in contact he's the one who who made\h
it happen so i guess um where i'd like to start\h\h
is um how you started martial arts briefly uh\h
i've read that you started with judo yes um\h\h
i started with judo as a freshman in college i\h
went to a small college uh reed college r-e-e-d\h\h
um and it was everyone had to take some\h
kind of pe class physical education\h\h
and uh there was a judo class being offered and\h
i thought well i was a lot more interesting than\h\h
basketball or baseball or you know the\h
usual stuff so i began uh practicing judo\h\h
we had a first q brown belt as our teacher and\h
we were in a funny like loft and i always was\h\h
afraid if you threw anybody high their feet would\h
hit the ceiling the whale sensei did with tenview
and i loved it my home was los angeles when i went\h
home for the summer i spent the summer training\h\h
with a wonderful judo teacher named hal sharp\h
and hal tried at the codicon uh in fact he was\h\h
the co-captain of the gaijin squad or whatever\h
they called it um and he was a very sweet very\h\h
wonderful guy i really enjoyed trey was a small\h
dojo in the san fernando valley in los angeles\h\h
we became friends and how planted\h
the seed um because i was sincere and\h\h
showed up a lot he said bob you know\h
you might think about going to japan\h\h
which i had never done and he said you know my\h
old teachers are still alive and if i wrote to\h\h
them i'm sure they'd be happy to put you up and\h
i thought wow what an incredible opportunity and\h\h
i started thinking about it and that thought\h
just stayed with me for the next few years um
and i would train with hal in the summers and\h
trained at um at college although i think the judo\h\h
class stopped after another year\h
because he graduated the teacher
and then i also started karate with ed\h
parker who was one of the very first\h\h
karate teachers in the united states and and\h
because i was again only there for the summer\h\h
ed and i arranged for me to have private lessons\h
with him so i would drive to pasadena which is\h\h
where his main dojo was and we'd train and that\h
was another wonderful door that opened for me\h\h
um so that was you know so i sort of knew\h
how to through a punch and take ukemi\h\h
um at least i i threw a punch in\h
the style of kempo karate which was
stronger than it was fast in many ways\h\h
and then i kept thinking gee i'd love to go\h
to japan i could train and you know i had read\h\h
zen in the art of archery and thought well what\h
a wonderful way to get it to know a culture
and i started applying for fellowships and i never\h
got one because i didn't have a good enough reason\h\h
i couldn't articulate you know this sort of\h
mystical notion of getting to know the soul\h\h
of japan through sweating um and i finally did\h
at the end of my second year in graduate school\h\h
this big package came sort of the last day\h
of the year school year and i looked at it it\h\h
was from the east west center in hawaii and my\h
first thought was damn they must have accepted\h\h
me because this is too big and substantial to\h
be a rejection letter and they said yeah bob\h\h
if you would like uh you can come for\h
two years all expenses paid fellowship\h\h
and you know then i went i negotiated and uh\h
for more time in japan because their normal\h\h
fellowship was a year and a half in hawaii in six\h
months in japan or china or whatever asian country\h\h
one wanted to go to and i thought well i may have\h
blown that but i really do want more time so i got\h\h
the longer stay while i was in hawaii i was\h
friendly with another student who was old was\h\h
a karate student and we talked about the martial\h
arts and one day he came up to me with this book\h\h
lovely illustrated large-sized book um this is\h
aikido i believe was the title it was by tohei\h\h
and i still remember opening it to ceo\h
sensei's picture and i sort of was just\h\h
struck by the power of his presence if you will\h
and i read memoir of the master that that section\h\h
in the book and i loved the um relatively short\h
i forget what the technical term is doka i guess\h\h
my japanese slowly slips away year by year when\h
kato sensei was alive he would come twice a year\h\h
and so get to practice translating and talking\h
with them all the time but now it's gone the\h\h
way of a lot of things as a move um and i i was\h
so taken with the book and something in me said\h\h
you've i've got to do this then i don't know what\h
it was you know it wasn't particularly logical um\h\h
i had heard of aikido before and even seen a\h
demonstration which i didn't think much of this\h\h
was early days in the earlier you know maybe 60\h
61. um you know and then multiple attack multiple\h\h
men attacks they were all holding back and i was\h
embarrassed in a way um that was in the u.s right\h\h
the demonstration uh the demonstration was done\h
by isao takahashi who was the man who introduced\h\h
aikido to the mainland um you know and he\h
was fairly competent but again it was sort\h\h
of key society well it was pre-key society\h
it was toe hey teach the americans and um\h\h
and he was an older man his uh his art was\h
really sword he was great kendo kendoka and\h\h
so i saw the book and i said i have to train\h\h
and it turns out the main dojo the hombu dojo\h
of hawaii was 15 minute drive from campus\h\h
so uh i started training a couple of\h
times a week in the beginner's class and i\h\h
really loved aikido and loved those sensei and\h
um so the first day i got to japan i took the\h\h
bus and found you know myself in that in wakamatsu\h
uh and it was the old dojo which i still miss it's\h\h
a beautiful traditional japanese wooden building\h
um and oh before i left uh i was yamamoto sensei
i think who was the chief instructor in hawaii\h
who was at great judoka judo sensei before he\h\h
met osensei he wrote me this beautiful letter of\h
introduction he sat me down in his little office\h\h
and he pulled out a really nice sheet of rice\h
paper made ink and started brushing a fancy letter\h\h
of introduction and told me to train well because\h
i was representing hawaii i was an american i\h\h
wasn't representing hawaii i didn't understand\h
that part of japanese culture particularly\h\h
so i went in and i handed my letter and there was\h
a it was a one-man office in those days the office\h\h
and this nice older man disappeared\h
he said you know thank you\h\h
and disappeared and i'm in in the genghan\h
wondering what to do seemed like forever and he\h\h
brought me to the room next to his which was the\h
room that doshu and osensei would sit in and um\h\h
i had full-time i mean i finished two years of\h
university conversational japanese and two years\h\h
of reading and writing and i just felt like a\h
schoolboy who stuttered you know i'm so honored\h\h
sensei i have no word i didn't say\h
i have no words but clearly i did
uh i'm sitting right you know in this small\h
room without sensei and and kisha marissa and\h\h
after a while we you know it's sort of uneasy\h
at both sides but you know there were no very\h\h
few foreigners were around so it sort of was a\h
big deal as you could see from those newspaper\h\h
articles you managed to take out of nowhere um\h
and i started training i oh kisho maru sensei\h\h
said did you bring your ghee and i said yes and he\h
took me out to the three o'clock afternoon class\h\h
and paired me up with an american who'd been\h
living in japan and that was the beginning\h\h
of my real aikido career i i jokingly said\h
i learned just enough in hawaii to get in
trouble so um that's how it started talking about\h
the uh the foreigners who were there at the time\h\h
um and about that aikido newspaper uh i'll i'll\h
put the i'll put up the clip there's an article in\h\h
the english version of the aikido newspaper that\h
states that you just arrived and at the same time\h\h
as henry connor can you remember who was there at\h
the time for reynolds except except you two well\h\h
it all merges you know i trained every day seven\h
days a week you know that routine i'm sure um and
robert nadeau was there in fact he was\h
the first one i trained with uh terry\h\h
dobson was living in tokyo but i had i didn't\h
meet him for months he was see running around
trying to import posters or something
henry was there henry allen and i became were\h
friendly and so was ken cartier virginia mayhew\h\h
came nine months later i think um and you know she\h
was sort of the mother of the group we were all\h\h
these are younger guys there was a guy well there\h
was a guy named john days who was african-american\h\h
only one ever trained at\h
home boo that was early years\h\h
uh strong he's very good there's a guy named\h
joe deischer who every once in a while you\h\h
see his picture people usually don't\h
identify him because they don't know him\h\h
but i knew joe joe joe actually had gone to read\h
you know i knew him from college and he's he was a\h\h
student of a believe it or not a japanese tai chi\h
teacher all right and that was what he focused on\h\h
although he also trained at hombu and he had\h
returned to the states and years later when\h\h
i started my own school i had him teach tai chi\h
so we stayed in touch there was joanne shimamoto\h\h
uh she she was training then george\h
willard that came later about a year later\h\h
and if you mention names i'm sure i would remember\h
them at one point i had a beautiful farewell card\h\h
i went back for the summer i went home\h
because my scholarship allowed me to do that\h\h
uh and there's you know it's a\h
big deal when you leave japan\h\h
you know it's a it's a it go it comes from seeing\h
you know the matson line steamer leave you know\h\h
so a lot of them came to see me off and\h
uh we were all we were very close there's\h\h
about a dozen people a dozen foreigners um\h
there was a swiss man who uh i think there was\h\h
geared wishnovsky can you study all those names\h
you probably remember them that that name is\h\h
the is the first time i i hear actually i\h
think the kendo as maybe judo as well um
that's that's all you know oh what happened is\h
i i created an aikido archive built on henry's\h\h
wonderful photographs which we archived at\h
part of the library of my school and it all\h\h
fell apart and it's sort of there but it's hard\h
not easy to access anymore and i sort of took\h\h
some of my best pictures to be scanned as well my\h
little collection and what i'm left with is a you\h\h
know is a lovely album with half the pictures\h
gone and i don't some of them i have in a bag
so i was um i was recently in contact with some\h
some students of henry because i also want to\h\h
write a piece on him for hidden and they've\h
been they they they've done the a lot of\h\h
digitizing of these pictures so you know that'd be\h
nice if you know if one day we could get those uh\h\h
all those pictures from those time uh you know\h
back together because as you said there are some\h\h
people who um whose name come up quite frequently\h
but others who are on pictures and you're not\h\h
quite sure who that may be or you or in some cases\h
i just have the name and i don't have much uh\h\h
much um like jodi i don't i don't have much on\h
except his name alan has identified most people\h\h
on the pictures that uh that that he showed me\h
uh but you know grabbing the pieces of history\h\h
of those various people is proving somewhat\h
somewhat challenging well i started to try to do\h\h
it systematically in fact i sat down um with john\h
stevens and which has lots of pictures himself\h\h
and and we started going through pictures and\h
talking about well who was that and when was that\h\h
it and you know after an hour it felt like we went\h
through only half a dozen right it was a very slow\h\h
process and um and i haven't i haven't really seen\h
john it's been some years now um well his health\h\h
hasn't been good as you probably know and he comes\h
out here he is there are some of the teachers here\h\h
love to have him teach at their dojos but\h
it's doesn't get around the way he used to\h\h
talking about um documenting what uh what happened\h
then i mean um i've had particular interest in\h\h
that english version of the aikido shin bun and um\h
i mean at least one of your articles was published\h\h
in there and i know that henry served as the\h
deputy editor i think it was his title associated\h\h
for some time um do you have any any particular\h
information on that on that newspaper how it\h\h
came about where the id came from to get it\h
made in english and and also perhaps how it\h\h
stopped because nowadays all the publications\h
are in japanese now now well uh i believe it\h\h
was uh it was started by bob nadeau he was living\h
close to the dojo and he was sort of a sotodashi
and trained very you know trained hard and\h
he was pretty clear he wanted to be an aikido\h\h
full-time aikido instructor which not\h
many people did not many foreigners\h\h
um so you know he had no japanese other than\h
you know can i have another scotch or a beer
in fact there aren't many of the foreigners\h
could speak japanese at all i mean there\h\h
was there was henry of course you know this\h
japanese canadian and there was me right um\h\h
and there may have been some well there may\h
there were some other japanese americans
yeah and my japanese got really quite good\h
because i was at ko university you know i would\h\h
train my routine ended up eight o'clock in the\h
morning class train some afterwards jump on the\h\h
uh yamate sen get to ko uh and then take\h
classes and later add research as well
and and then i became a student of tempu\h
nakamura and one week a month i would attend\h\h
his lectures at night so that was a very full\h
i would often leave the house you know quarter\h\h
after seven or something like that walk to\h
the dojo i was staying in ichigaya yeah okay\h\h
i stayed with don drager i did oh okay the famous\h
house yeah yet another another you know link that\h\h
we might want to explore with yeah yeah um\h
i walked to the dojo and then i would leave\h\h
for ko and then you know if i would have dinner\h
with someone or go to temple's lecture i wasn't\h\h
getting back till 11 at night right thank god i\h
was young and training i couldn't do those things
one that came to mind that came to mind um still\h
about that newspaper sid white is is uh is uh\h\h
credited as the editor of this since the first\h
issue and as you said indeed uh bob nadeau has\h\h
some article in the various early parts did who\h
was that sid white uh person i i've never seen uh\h\h
what was his name again white i don't remember it\h
but you know people would come and often not stay\h\h
for very long uh so yeah we all said some\h
people that were in the military who would\h\h
come down weekends haven't even sort of commuted\h
to their regular jobs but lived in tokyo so\h\h
uh i i really don't know isn't it okay okay um\h
so uh so yeah i mean living in ichigaya you were\h\h
literally like you know 15 minutes walk from\h
from hamburg so i presume it was more like 25.
because i used to live in uh in yotsuya\h
so i i uh you know that that work yeah\h\h
it's a perfect warm-up indeed indeed indeed i\h
used to go yeah i used to go there jogging and\h\h
and back and um so and and i'm\h
especially interested in how my you know\h\h
how life might have been at the time and\h
i keep asking my my senpai people who were\h\h
there at the time i've asked i asked christian\h
this year i asked the dj boys people like this\h\h
you know did you take some pictures of how things\h
were and and even henry or alan all they have is\h\h
his uh you know pictures of osensei and hombu\h
but i want to see how what life was like and\h\h
you know how the the urban urban landscape if\h
you could call it that was like at the time um\h\h
so you were like you were at ko um where was the\h
campus uh at that time i was at the um there were\h\h
two campuses there was one sort of out of town it\h
was a larger one that was near tokyo tower okay
okay and actually when i first moved to\h
japan i moved i lived for a while in nakano
yeah and um then i lived for a while\h\h
i had a nice little room in a japanese\h
temple right near the mita campus
and and then finally i met don drager i knew his\h
picture from the back of his books right and uh\h\h
there's a famous it was a famous bookstore one\h
of the only ones with lots of english books on\h\h
on the ginza i can't remember the name now and i\h
met him i introduced myself and he was interested\h\h
because i don't think he'd met any americans\h
that were training an aikido full-time right\h\h
so when a room opened up he you know he offered\h
it to me and i thought that's perfect because\h\h
going to aikido rapidly became more important in\h
its own way than going going to the university\h\h
so so i moved i moved into the house with two\h
other judoka and a woman who worked in tokyo that\h\h
was never around so they were oh and they were\h
one was canadian one was british of the of the uh\h\h
the other guys and they were relatively relatively\h
new to judo maybe showdown or something like that
through dragon did you did you get the chance\h
to practice any of the the koryo bujutsu that's\h\h
what he he did mostly i think he was i think\h
he was fed up with the politics of judah etc
i mean for example i know hal sharp came back\h
to the united states i believe as a knee down\h\h
and stayed as a knee down for years and years and\h
years and then suddenly toward the end of his life\h\h
there were more say or you know it was no longer\h
the old guard in charge and suddenly they finally\h\h
promoted them to eighth donna or knightsdon um but\h
yeah there was all that political not of course\h\h
there's politics everywhere and i never would\h
have gotten promoted to a thon if it wasn't for\h\h
bob corman god bless him oh really well well he\h
pushed and he was very good at documenting stuff\h\h
and the fact you know i really was a student of oh\h
senseis not everybody i realized that but i was um\h\h
and i trained with all the\h
homebrew teachers except i was\h\h
my first year is really closer to saito\h
sensei okay then second year osawa sensei\h\h
then i went back to the states got my degree\h
and went back to japan for postdoc research\h\h
and then after about seven years and i\h
built a dojo up at the uc santa cruz campus\h\h
it was a wonderful time to be teaching aikido\h
and i was really into the meditative spiritual\h\h
part of it and i did all the crazy things you\h
did when you're young having people line up and\h\h
take you know you have to take who can me over\h
five or six people and you know all that stuff\h\h
and i threw in tohei's key exercises tempos\h
uh the key and and mental exercises um
so i really had quite a few students and three\h
of my students i forget exactly three of my best\h\h
students sort of wanted to go to japan and really\h
study seriously um and they they met another santa\h\h
cruz student who sort of dabbled in aikido and\h
she said there's this amazing dojo in shingu ah